liberty and justice for all that's what
this flag is supposed to mean for all of
us you may remember this uh during the
2020 George Floyd Floyd riots when they
were burning down Pep Boys and Targets
in the name of diversity Equity
inclusion and all that good stuff uh
talking about how rioting and no justice
no peace that's really an allegiance to
the American flag you know all this
stuff about the flag and kneeling you
know got me thinking about the Pledge of
Allegiance you know I pledge allegiance
to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liberty and justice for all and we
all said that pledge growing up here in
the United States and going back to it
liberty and justice for all that's what
this flag is supposed to mean for all of
us and so when people kneel when people
stand up in protest it's specifically
what we pledge to do our entire lives in
school the pledge to the United States
of America and our flag for liberty and
justice for all and when people chant no
justice no peace to me that's what they
mean that's what I hear and when people
kneel they're not turning away from the
flag they're turning towards the flag
and pushing for justice for all have you
as you may have noted in the upper
corner of that thing that was a video
that was put out by the official NBA
account during the riots uh the NBA of
course also put black lives matter logos
on the court we now know that the black
lives matter movement was a complete
giant grift it never set set a black
sent a black kid to college it never
helped black businessmen open a small
business or anything like that and again
here's where Mark cubin is just confused
of course you allowed to kneels for the
flag if you so choose um just liberty
and justice for all we have no laws that
that discriminate against anyone in this
country on the basis of their skin uh
what most people were upset by when it
came to that that Summer of Love in 2020
is that they were burning down stores
and where I lived in Los Angeles off
Ventura Avenue which is a major drag
there in Los Angeles that all of the
stores were boarded up and they all put
BLM signs and they would say how many
employes of color they had there because
they didn't want their stores to be
burned down in in the name of Tolerance
and diversity and love so there is a
difference between peaceful protest and
burning down stores or say what they're
doing now as they've morphed it into a
Hamas protest uh blocking Bridges going
to people's homes etc
etc